hey hows it going bros it's PEWDIEPIE!
it is my honor to be playing Uncharted 4 for you bros
we're doing a daily LET'S PLAY of this game
it is one of my favorite games i've played
in a really long time
if you check in right now
go watch the first episode
i'll still be here
But for now we're in some
deep fucking shit man
I don't think i jumped that right
Oh i did ok
OH MY GOD OH MY GOD
Ok ok ok
what do i do
*mumbleing*
OK
UHHHHH....
it just went sneaky on us
*trying to speak itailian*
Italians crack me up man
Ok, let's go this way
Nate, please, thank you
Down or up, down or up, down or up
Uhhhh...
Down
So was the question isn't it
There you go Nate
Nate my mate
Come on Nate
There it is
Look at this fucking shit
Why don't we just jump in the water
We will be done
Ok, easy now
Easy now
There it is
Alright, Let's go up here and see what hap-
AHH...
No
Are they talking about cake?
???
Oh!
He saw me
Ok
Looks like we can't take this road
Whoa, that scared me a little bit
I thought I fucked up
Ok
Here we go
Let's do this shit Nate style baby
Or we could have just done that
What the fuck did I just do? Are you serious?
I'm such an idiot
Ok, we gotta be careful now
These people are fucking crazy man
Italians man
I don't know what to tell you man
I don't even know where do we even go technically
But it always flows so nicely
Here we go, we gotta make a jump for it
Oh god, ok, here we go
Come on
Come on now
Go
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god
Ok, alright, let's just go in
Ha ha ha...
We'll find some guns
We'll kill some people
No big deal
That's what I do
Ok
Uhh...
I think it's this way
Nate, like what
kind of drugs are you taking
Thank you
Sometimes, I don't know what to tell you Nate
Sometimes, I just don't know what to tell you
Oh god, hide
I learn.. the only Italian I learn, is from listening to Marzia's mom
speak
haha
Cause she speak Italian to me even though I don't understand
But I recognise words, you know
(inaudible)
1 second, pretty much. I think
Son of a bitch, just look somewhere else asshole
Alright, we just gotta time it right
What?
What the fuck? How did they see me?
That was so... Strange
They actually don't see me
Oh god, he's gonna walk straight into me. Oh thank god
Ok
hahaha
See I'm so good at Italian, I can practically can speak it fluently
Jesus Christ, that was close
Who's driving that car?
What the fuck is going on there?
What is this, a James Bond movie?
Fucking rich people man, I
Oh my god stop, I want to see that, they're so fast
Sorry
Ok, we're fine
I got shot at
But I made it
Alright?
We're out in the open
Go go go go go
Come on
Uhh!
This is making me so anxious
OH, oh oh
Oh, that's where we're suppose to go
Oh, you kidding me!
That's super far dude!
Ok, we can do this bros
We can do this
We came this far
Never mind, we're too short
There it is
Maybe this will help
I have a good feeling that's not going to work
But let's see
Ayy
Neither are you
I told you
hahahaha
Is she talking about my dick?
Sorry, sorry
hahaha
Told you
Oh
Damn
Fucking British girls
Jesus Christ
Uh
Uh uhb
Ok, alright, we're gonna...
She- Look at her
biceps, Jesus Christ
Fucking hell, I can't fight her
Look at her fucking arms
They're bigger than my legs
Bitch, sorry
Bitch, oh fuck, ass
Sorry about that
Ok, you attack
Oh my god, she's so much better than...
Oh, a butt touch
Oh I see
If only I knew how to play
I'm getting my ass beat
What do you think I have it?
uhhhh....
uh ha, ha
What fucking language are you speaking?
What, what do you mean clarify?
hahaha
There's no way I can beat her, she's way too strong man
ahahaha
Ow
Dude
Ohhh
Ah shit
Holy! Oh my god
Oh my god
Oh boy
Oh, OH, oh oh
Well then, that turned out great
yehahaha
Oh god
I'm trying, I'm trying
"Good news, I got a gun"?
Oh my god, I have no idea if I'm going the right way
Oh my god
Oh god
How did they not see me
Jesus
What do I do
Should I really do this?
You're fucking insane Nate
You're fucking INSANE
Oh my god
I'm sweating just thinking...
Oh my god Nate
For fuck's sake Nate
Sure no one heard that
Ooo
Dude that was close
Fucking hell
Don't get shot again
Don't throw it to me
Oh I got a gun
Hey
Mamma mia pizzari-
How do they not die from one shot like
thats
There you go
There you go, right in the pooper
Yeah, no big deal
Ok, I'm guessing I have to climb here
Can I reload?
Damn, that's a fast reload man
Hmm
Umm
Maybe go back again?
No?
Or maybe we just go down here. I don't know. Let's pick up their ammo
OH GOD
Why do I mark the enemies? Why would I do that?
So I can see where they are?
Ok, fair enough
Let's try to not kill them
I think that's always like
The nicer way
Of doing things, not murdering people
You know what I mean
We are talking about 400 million
bucks, you know what I mean
I get it
I get it Nate
I pup, I pup some
(no idea what's he saying)
Can we just go drop here?
C'mon, that wasn't even that high!
What the hell
What! Are you? Ok
Well fine you know what
Fine, I don't even care
Let's go for it
Oh, this is tricky man
Go around the corner, NICE
That was nice
Ok, we got this
We're almost there
fuck
We're almost there, we're almost there
fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck
Oh, fuck's sake
Ah, shit
There's so many of them
Where are you
Should we just fucking spray them down?
I feel like..
I feel like a better player if I can
do this undetected, so I'm gonna...
I'm gonna try
I'm gonna try, do you believe in me bros?
Of course you don't. Thank you, I appreciate that
What the fuck are they doing? Fucking each other?
They're definitely fucking each other. Look at that fucking shit
What the fuck is that?
He's just like
I do that to. When I'm looking for people especially
They glitched out man
Look, they're stuck
Should I just spray them down then?
Maybe if I let them discover me, they'll
wait
See, now they move, ok
Ok
Just need that guy to move
Thank you
Alright, now maybe we can...
Go, go, go, go, go, go
Oh my god, oh my god
Yes, ok we did it
Nice, nicely done
Jump, oo my god
Ok
Alright, cars are leaving, and so am I
Grass, I like grass
Alright, there's got to be people here right?
Jesus
Are we suppose to move this?
This looks like something we would've moved
But why?
Ah shit, they're coming
Ok
How do we get down there?
Oh god
Ok, he walks down there
Maybe we can do the same
Pewdiepato?
Ohh?
Ok, we're fine
Ok, so we can take them out
What happened, they saw me. Ok, fuck
Umm
Shit
Who the fuck is shooting me?
Damn it
Fucked it up
Oh they're fucking everywhere
Jesus
Oh god, I didn't see him
Shit
OH MY GOD
Well that guy got knocked the fuck out, Jesus Christ
Fuck that guy
Oh I see, I see, I see it
Right in the middle. This should've been obvious
Don't fucking shoot
Oh fuck it, I'll just run
I'll just run, I'll just run
Ok, now I'm really getting fucking tired of your fucking piece of shit
Fucking shoot your penis off, Jesus
Oh great, I don't have a weapon now
Come on, take him out, take him out
Ohh
OHHH
You got fucked
Bitch
Sorry, I re- I
I'm trying my best at least, alright?
Oh I could have just walked up?
Why did no one tell me?
Alright, fuck it
Let's go back up again
Ah, it's gotta be here somewhere. It's gotta be here somewhere
Where are you, where are you
Alright
Yep
Got it
OH!
And this is our exit
OHHHHHH
SHIT
AHHHHHH SHIT
AAH WHOA AHH WHAT?
What the fuck happe- Hey
Hows it's going, my name is Pewdiepie
How's it going
Fucking coping my lines all the...
HEY
Pop out, pop out
Fucking asshole, got a shotgun
Jesus
*licking mustache*
Who's shooting me?
You fucking dickhead
fuck
Jesus Christ
No I'm down for that
Ok, well I'm fucking dead
*dead*
Ok, let's try that.
Got him
Walked right in my trap, bitch
Who the f...? Oh god
WHOA! WHOA! NATHAN DRAKE BITCH
That's right mother fucker
You want some of this?
YOU WANT SOME OF THESE?
Oh
What's good?
I fight-
I fight air
What're you gonna do about it
Yeah :)
That was cool, right?
Fuck me
JAYSUS CRUST (Jesus Christ)
AH
how do I aim?
How do I aim???
There it is
Thank you, brah
Thanks, bra-
no
Let me reload
Reload
Thanks
Where's the other one
Where are they
Oh my fucking God
MOVE, are you crazy
"Hold still, would ya'?"
Is it painful to see me aim, cuz
it's fucking hard, man
I'm not used to this shit
Gimme a mouse and a keyboard and we're good, man
Where are you going
Shoot his ass
Oh
Ah
Changing weapon again
What the fuck was that
I'M TRYING
OMG
Hey, how're you doing
*under the sea song*
Oh I was suppose to go inside the car-
Can we run for it (3x)
YES That is a yes
Let- go, go, go. go
C'mon (nth times)
Easy
oh my god
So easy
huh ey huh
Guilty Americans
We did it!
High five
*high five*
That was...
hard. I like it
It's challenging
You don't want a game to be too easy, alright
*smooch* Beautiful
Ahah yeah you do
Nothing in it?
He's trolling
Yeah I know it
We're gonna dig up his grave?
Not the graveyard
Ahah
She wasn't
Don't lie to her
She's not stupid, you know, she's gonna find out
The weather is never fine over here, alright
Never
Ok we're going
This is so COOL
God dammit It's so cool
Chapter 8
The Grave of Henry Avery
Look at this SHIT
I'm such a sucker for visuals
Yeah he fucking stab a prison guard like, what the fuck
Why did we ever work with that fucking asshole
he's creeping me out
ooh sliding time
Nice
Heuh
yeayeh
So where are we going
Down I suppose
We gotta go around
Oh God this is gonna creep me out
Damn that look so cool
Sorry, I had the biggest boner for this game
and no, you know what
I'm not apologizing
If I wanna
have sex with this game
No one should tell me if I can or cannot
Hey here we go
Nail it
There's even equipment for us
Amazing
*gasp* That's the company
No
Are you kidding me
Asshole
You're the asshole
I wanna get a headshot
There it is
It's so satisfying
It's was the same in The Last of Us
So nice to just fucking pop them in the popper
Oh my God, is that a...
That's amazing
Scotland, we're in Scotland, mate
You like some perp- a pine?
Fuck I don't
Sorry
So the treasure's like 400 million
surely if you hire this many people
for like, shooting merch and shit
that's gotta cause equal amount, you know
Listen, I'm just thinking about the...
woah
What does Shoreline mean?
(shoreline: the line where shore and water meet)
(shore: the land along the edge of a sea, lake, broad river, etc)
Nevermind. That was the dumbest thing I ever asked
Don't answer that, please
(no)
We're gonna fine some cigarettes
Or dynamite
yeah man
yeah
Whoa
Okay
Alright
Where are we gonna throw it, though
Here?
I don't
Yeah
Ok
Well what do we got
Uh, we can push something I suppose
What do we got over here
these?
What are you doing kicking that
You know there's dynamite around here
There we go
This is just what we needed
Do we gotta blow that shit up again
Oh we gotta blow up again
This is crazy, dude
Ah, mate, you should, ok
uh no it's just ah
Fucking hell, Nate. You're crazy
You crazy, man
We could just moves some fucking boxes but
No Nate
Nate's gotta do the high way
Surely there's no way the wheels help at fucking (?)